the phenotracker project allows you to
get high throughput data from video
monitoring
of animal models of human disease so you
you here you can see a little preview of
what the analysis looks like and if you
scroll down
you'll see a lot more information about
what is being done as well as some of
the history of the project that we
developed
together with ucsf and darpa
now you can also learn more about the
hardware that we use
which is a an insert to the lid with
these modules
and you can see how the modules that are
easily detachable from the lid
could be converted into multiple types
of sensors like
microphones uv ready uv
illuminated camera capturing
and thermal camera as well so you can
see here an example of what the full
cage kind of looks like now if we
go inside the tracker software here i'm
gonna
log in with my google account
so after you log in you'll see that you
have a dashboard of all of the
experiments that are ongoing and you can
kind of
go into a real-time view if you go down
here to the experiment
tab so let's take a look at this first
one
you see here that there are three cages
essentially three
mice here's a principal component
analysis obviously right now with just
three mice
it does not make that much sense but you
can change it to the day view
and you can see how for each one of the
mice you have multiple days
and so this green mouse which is
uh mouse 26 so this one is a little bit
different from the rest right so they're
all kind of cluster right here
and here you can see that starting to go
sideways so now you can also go
into the dashboard and start seeing
what does the data actually look like so
here you have a real-time view
of the cages they consist of three
cameras each
those cameras capture the animal and the
animal is tracked so when you see these
three
dots the largest dot shows the head
and then this is the body and this is
the tail and here you've got
the data so you can see what the data
actually looks like
now you saw that 26 is a little bit
different from the rest
and indeed right away we can see that
okay it's sleeping in the middle
these are sleeping on the side so it
does look a little bit different this
also has high
temperature composed of these compared
to these so there is something going on
now if you go to the dashboard right
here
you can see a real-time view with a heat
map
of where the location is in the past
period of time of just maybe 10 30
minutes
and if you scroll down you will start
seeing
the data so if you scroll
if you kind of enlarge this you can see
the area changes and we can remove that
now you can see the speed
let's remove some of these
okay so here you have speed
size and temperature right so you have
these spikes
in uh temperature for example which is
interesting
now here at the bottom you have a view
this is an automated system to track
different types of activities so for
example slow movement moderate movement
fast movement
you can see that the fast movement does
correlate with temperature but not
perfectly you can see that some of the
temperature is considered to be high
now this could be because of the camera
normalization in the beginning you can
kind of normalize everything if you
place an object with the same
temperature to make sure that it's
capturing the right kind of information
and obviously once you've seen
this visually you would like to analyze
and understand
what are the differences between these
different mice or between different days
so that's why we have here a section
called analysis you can also
export the data that will come in a
table format so you can analyze it on
your computer
or you can perform some analysis right
here including
seasonality decomposition and some other
types of comparisons so in fact if you
want to read more about
what types of analyses are possible you
can see some examples here
this is a time warp difference
between healthy and sick conditions
you can see that some of the analysis is
briefly described here
and importantly you can develop a model
of
condition changes over time so this is a
little preview
of the phenotracker project and
you can learn more by going to
fino.tracker.comtracker is with
trkir.com and learn much more about it